latinoamérica a una región azotada
económicamente por la pandemia para el
fondo monetariointernacional la
creciente inflación es uno de los
grandes problemas que deben enfrentar
las economías el aumento del precio de
los alimentos deja menos recursos para
gastar en otros bienes en argentina- el
acumulado de la inflación hasta octubre
de este año fue del 41 8% habitantes de
la ciudad de buenos aires- que viven en
la boca y otros barrios desfavorecidos
han tenido que acudir a comedores
comunitarios una situación impensable en
otros tiempos porque nunca tuvieran
sociedad siempre tuve trabajo y bueno y
ganaba bien después de la pandemia fue
donde no conseguía trabajo y hasta el
momento todo lo días mandó currículo y
no me llama los confinamientos
obligatorios y los cierres de 2020
dejaron secuelas también en brasil la
principal economía de la región los
precios de los alimentos se dispararon
un 14 por ciento en los últimos 12 meses
recibimos un sueldo yo soy limpiadora
pero no alcanza para pagar el alquiler
la luz el agua vivimos como podemos
estamos aquí luchando contra el hambre
hay gente que está en peor situación
méxico en américa del norte también ha
sido golpeado por la crisis en el tercer
trimestre del año presentó un
estancamiento en el crecimiento con
respecto al trimestre anterior debido en
parte al coletazo de la crisis mundial
de la cadena de suministros el país ha
disminuido las cifras de desempleo pero
cerca del 55 por ciento de la fuerza
laboral trabaja en la informalidad según
la comisión económica para américa
latina y el caribe cepal la región
tendrá un crecimiento del 59 por ciento
en 2021 pero eso no garantiza que la
actividad vuelva a niveles pre
pandémicos